voilà notre invité ce matin c'est le
journaliste Hugo Clément bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation bon
matin pour ceux qui nous regardent
depuis l'étranger je rappelle que vous
êtes engagés dans la défense de
l'environnement vous avez réalisé de
nombreux documentaires des enquêtes des
livres et notamment celui-ci les lapins
ne mangent pas de carottes aux éditions
Fayard vous partez en gros de cette idée
reçue que les lapins ne mangent pas de
carottes dans la nature pour aborder la
question animale nos rapports avec les
animaux que ce soit dans notre
alimentation nos habitudes nos
traditions nos loisirs avec beaucoup de
guillemets aussi et en parlant de
loisirs on va parler de la chasse pour
commencer parce que ce sujet il est
d'actualité en France le week-end passé
a été marqué encore par de nombreux
accidents de chasse on en découvre un
peu tous les jours sur les réseaux
sociaux le gouvernement a décidé de
légiférer en tout cas il envisage
notamment d'instaurer un délit
d'alcoolémie ou encore dans cette région
des des demi-journées de chasse ou la
chasse s'arrêterait le dimanche à midi
est-ce que ça va dans le bon sens
oui enfin tout ce qui va dans la
sécurisation des citoyens qui ne sont
pas chasseurs qui sont quand même
l'écrasante majorité de la population il
y a à peu près 1 million de chasseurs
actifs en France ça veut dire que 66
millions de Françaises et de Français ne
sont pas chasseurs ça va dans le bon
sens après j'attends de voir les
annonces je sais pas ce qui va être
annoncé précisément mais c'est de
l'ordre ce qui est demandé par les gens
qui habitent à la campagne et qu'on a un
peu ras-le-bol de se balader la peur au
ventre ce qui est demandé par les
associations de protection de la nature
c'est d'instaurer au moins un jour sans
chasse par semaine que ce soit le
mercredi le dimanche peut-être même deux
jours sans chasse d'éviter la chasse
pendant les vacances scolaires aussi
pour que les familles qui vivent à la
campagne ou celles qui vont à la
campagne pour se promener puisse le
faire sans avoir peur de se prendre une
balle tout simplement je pense que c'est
la la liberté de circulation et la
sécurité des Français qui doit primer
sur un loisir qui consiste à utiliser
des armes à feu mais pour ça faut déjà
qu'il y ait des contrôles parce que
c'est pas vraiment le cas aujourd'hui
mais il y en a peu on a vu encore ces
images de chasseurs pendant le week qui
tire ah bah tout près de cycliste qui
qui heureusement
sur le casque il y a eu aussi la vidéo
du jeune femme qui avec sa fille dehors
et là là il s'agit tout simplement de
non respect des règles de chasse elles
existent un permis aujourd'hui il y a
des règles observer à chaque fois qu'il
y a un accident en tout cas dans la
plupart des cas c'est qu'effectivement
les règles de sécurité n'ont pas été
respectées il y a un chasseur récemment
qui a tiré sur une mère de famille avec
ses deux enfants en bas âge qui les a
touchés avec des plombs et il s'est
justifié en disant qu'il avait été
ébloui par le soleil bon une des règles
de base à la chasse c'est quand on a pas
identifié clairement sa cible on ne tire
pas et la plupart des accidents cette
règle n'est pas respectée on peut se
rappeler de morgankine un jeune homme
qui a été tué alors qu'il était dans son
jardin en train de couper du bois et le
tireur a dit qu'il l'avait confondu avec
un sanglier ça c'est plus acceptable en
fait il y a eu un je pense pendant des
décennies les chasseurs ont été habitués
à faire ce qu'il voulait dans la
campagne il y avait pas les réseaux
sociaux il y avait pas les téléphones
portables pour filmer donc on ne savait
pas tout ce qui se passait et
aujourd'hui il y a un vrai football qui
monte on est au courant de ces accidents
de chasse beaucoup plus qu'avant parce
que les réseaux sociaux parce que tout
ça est filmé et c'est plus acceptable et
il faut il faut avancer vous êtes quand
même contre la chasse de loisirs vous
dites que vous n'êtes pas contre le
principe de la chasse non quand il
s'agit de besoin pour s'alimenter si on
chasse pour se nourrir je vois pas
comment on peut être contre si on se les
dans certains pays certaines populations
ont besoin de chasser pour survivre on
va pas aller expliquer aux tribus
indigènes en Amazonie que il faut
arrêter de chasser ou aux gens qui
vivent en Sibérie qu'il faut pas chasser
voilà il y a des gens qui ont besoin de
ça pour vivre en France c'est du loisir
en France on relâche des millions de
faisans et de perdrix d'élevage qu'on a
élevé dans des enclos pour s'amuser à
leur tirer dessus c'est pas un impératif
alimentaire donc à partir du moment où
c'est un loisir ça doit passer après la
sécurité des Françaises des Français
mais il y a une idée reçue le respect
des animaux c'est la question de la
régulation aussi des des populations
c'est souvent un argument qui est qui
est avançait on doit réguler par exemple
la population de sanglier qui qui
habitent des cultures alors on prend
toujours par exemple du sanglier faut
savoir que le sanglier c'est moins de 5%
des animaux qui sont tués à la chasse ça
veut dire que 95% des animaux tués à la
chasse ne sont pas des sangliers 80%
d'entre eux sont des oiseaux et comme je
viens de vous le dire parmi les animaux
les plus tués à la chasse en France il y
a les faisant les perdrix d'élevage donc
on les élève on les lâche dans la nature
et on les tue là va falloir m'expliquer
où est la régulation quel est l'intérêt
de réguler des populations qu'on a
nous-mêmes introduit dans la nature donc
il y a peut-être un enjeu de régulation
pour certaines espèces très
particulières encore qu'on pourrait en
discuter parce que les scientifiques
sont pas du tout unanime là-dessus mais
pour la grande majorité des animaux tu
es à la chasse il y a aucun enjeu de
régulation il y a aucun dégât qui est
fait au culture et c'est simplement tuer
des animaux pour s'amuser donc ça
aujourd'hui c'est plus vraiment
acceptable surtout face à l'effondrement
de la biodiversité qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et pour les sangliers
d'ailleurs vous expliquer qu'il y a une
sorte de paradoxe c'est qu'on fait de
plus en plus de culture de maïs pour
nourrir le bétail l'agriculture
intensive ce qui fait que ça attire les
sangliers et ça encourage à la
reproduction de la population la plupart
des dégâts causés par les sangliers sur
les cultures sont effectivement sont
causé sur les champs de maïs les
sangliers adorent le maïs et la part du
maïs dans les cultures a explosé ces
dernières décennies on en fait de plus
en plus parce qu'il faut nourrir
effectivement comme vous le dites les
millions d'animaux qui sont enfermés
dans les élevages intensifs donc plus il
y a de maïs plus les sangliers vont
faire des dégâts sur le maïs et plutôt
que se dire il faut éliminer les
sangliers peut-être qu'on pourrait se
dire il faut changer de modèle agricole
sortir de cette agriculture intensive
qui consiste à faire des centaines des
milliers d'hectares de maïs pour les
animaux des élevages intensifs et
revenir vers des cultures qui servent
avant tout à nourrir les humains et puis
surtout les sangliers sont nourris par
les chasseurs ça aussi il faut le dire
et les gens qui vivent à la campagne ne
le savent très bien pendant l'hiver il y
a ce qu'on appelle la grainage donc les
chasseurs vont déposer de la nourriture
pour les sangliers dans la forêt ce qui
évidemment renforce les populations de
sangliers puisque ça les aide à passer
l'hiver etc il y a eu pendant des
décennies en France des lâchés de
sangliers on a importé des sangliers
d'autres pays pour implanter renforcer
les populations de sangliers en France
pour chasser donc aujourd'hui les
chasseurs viennent nous dire oui il faut
réguler les sangliers c'est un peu de
leur faute quand même l'explosion une
population de sangliers on parlait de
l'agriculture intensive de l'élevage
intensif c'est un de vos premiers
chapitres dans dans ce livre vous dites
que cabane des animaux ça se fait pas
sans souffrance quel que soit les
dispositifs chaque jour en France 3
millions d'animaux abattus pour la
consommation nos régimes alimentaires il
doivent changer ok d'accord mais comment
on doit tous devenir végétarien demain
non pas du tout c'est ce que j'explique
dans le livre le message c'est pas de
dire soyons tous végétariens ou vegan
parce que c'est pas possible il y a
toujours des gens qui voudront manger de
la viande en revanche il faut qu'on
diminue la consommation globale on peut
pas manger autant de viande que ce qu'on
mange aujourd'hui et vouloir sortir de
l'élevage intensif c'est pas possible
quand on regarde les sondages il y a 90%
des Françaises et des Français qui sont
contre l'élevage intensif mais en même
temps si tout le monde achetait autant
de viande qu'aujourd'hui en se
fournissant uniquement dans les élevages
artisanaux ça ne marcherait pas assez
impossible de répondre à la demande de
viande actuelle en faisant de l'élevage
artisanal si on veut faire que de
l'élevage artisanale plus respectueux
des animaux plus respectueux de
l'environnement il faut réduire
consommation de viande qui est beaucoup
trop élevée aujourd'hui et qui est très
élevé dans les pays riches et ça il faut
le rappeler en France on consomme à peu
près 86 kg de viande par an et par
personne la moyenne des pays africains
c'est 15 kg de viande par an et par
personne donc l'industrie de la viande
au niveau mondial nourrit
essentiellement les pays riches qui sont
les pays qui ont le moins de
problématiques pour de sous-nutrition
pour l'instant parce que l'Occident est
un peu un modèle pour certains pays en
Chine par exemple le beurre commence à
être introduit dans l'alimentation et là
aussi on va rencontrer des problèmes
dans des populations là on compte on
parle d'un milliard et demi d'habitants
oui bien sûr mais la situation
aujourd'hui c'est que ce sont
essentiellement les pays riches qui
consomment le plus de viande et donc
c'est à nous les habitants de ces
pays-là qui ne faisons pas face à des
problèmes de sous nutrition en France ça
existe peut-être il y a peut-être
quelques milliers de personnes qui qui
n'arrivent pas à se nourrir mais la
grande majorité de la population n'a pas
de problème de sous-nutrition ce qui est
pas le cas en Afrique par exemple donc
il faut réduire cette consommation de
viande ça veut pas dire arrêter ça veut
pas dire ne plus faire de barbecue ça ne
veut pas dire ne pas manger une
entrecôte de temps en temps mais réduire
et avoir une consommation plus
responsable et arrêtez d'en manger tous
les jours un autre combat dans ce livre
c'est la question les animaux en
captivité que ce soit les dauphins les
animaux de cirque les éléphants en
balade en Thaïlande ou même des faux
refuges pour pour fauve ce que vous
dénoncez c'est d'abord l'usage des
animaux pour le divertissement humain et
là aussi c'est un contrat argument qui
vous est souvent opposé c'est clé les
les autres et les formes de d'arche de
Noé pour une certaine préservation de
d'espèces en danger ce que c'est vrai
alors je parle effectivement des eaux je
parle aussi de la corrida par exemple un
ou là il y a aucun argument pour
justifier le fait de torturer un taureau
pour s'amuser mais sur les eaux oui il
se présente comme des arches de Zoé de
Noé pardon excusez-moi il se présente
comme des gens arches de Zoé qui
préservent les espèces en danger la
question principale à régler pour les
espèces en danger c'est de préserver
leur habitat naturel parce que garder
des gorilles par exemple qui sont
menacés d'extinction dans la nature en
captivité ça sert à quoi si on n'arrive
pas à protéger l'habitat naturel de ces
animaux parce que s'il disparaissent
c'est que leur habitat naturel est en
train de disparaître et si un jour il
disparaissent totalement de la nature
quel intérêt de les garder en captivité
puisque l'on ne pourra jamais les
réintroduire sur la si leur habitat
naturel a disparu donc la priorité avant
tout c'est d'arrêter de détruire les
espaces naturels dans lesquels vivent
les animaux c'est pas en les gardant
derrière des barreaux qu'on va protéger
ses espaces et puis il y a des pratiques
qui sont assez surprenantes moi je ne
connaissais pas c'est l'abattage
d'animaux dans certains eaux oui bah
pour les espèces menacées mais pour les
autres ah des espèces menacées aussi on
abat dans certains eaux on fait des
euthanasies de gestion dans certains
zones notamment les gorilles des
certaines espèces de gorilles qui se
reproduisent très bien en captivité
alors qu'elles sont menacées
d'extinction critique au niveau naturel
et il y a des exemples j'en parle dans
le livre ou des eaux face à une
surpopulation de gorille à l'intérieur
du zoo on euthanasié des animaux qui
n'était pas malade qui était en pleine
santé parce que ils arrivaient pas à
gérer cette population qu'ils avaient
pas assez de place dans leurs enclos
donc on est dans une situation
complètement aberrante qui est dénoncée
d'ailleurs par les scientifiques et les
primatologues c'est que on a une espèce
menacé d'extinction dans la nature on en
a trop dans les eaux donc on les cuit
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à gérer ça
montre bien que la captivité n'est pas
forcément une solution à la à la
conservation ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
jamais passer par la captivité ça peut
avoir un intérêt de placer certains
animaux sauvages en captivité par
exemple le temps de les soigner avant de
les relâcher le temps de les faire se
reproduire pour relâcher leurs
progénique moi je suis pas contre la
captivité s'il y a un objectif à la fin
de renforcer les populations naturelles
mais garder des animaux juste pour les
garder l'intérêt en termes de
conservation et assez faible donc ce
soit pour la chasse l'élevage ou les
loisirs vous appelez à penser nos
rapports avec les animaux avec humilité
on comprend bien quand même qu'on est
dans une époque de clivage que le le
clash le clivage avec les chasseurs ou
les éleveurs ça résout rien changer son
comportement ça doit ça doit passer par
l'information par par l'injonction sinon
ça va produire un effet inverse alors
exactement il faut pas dire aux gens ce
qu'il faut faire faire il faut donner
les informations qui permettent aux gens
de faire leur choix en connaissance de
cause et eux-mêmes et je pense que
l'information c'est le vecteur principal
si vous savez pas ce qui se passe dans
les élevages intensifs si vous savez pas
ce qui se passe dans la nature dans les
eaux dans les cirques vous pouvez pas
changer vos comportements si quand vous
allez en vacances en Thaïlande vous
savez pas ce que ça implique de faire
une balade à dos d'éléphant vous allez
continuer à le faire parce que c'est
sympa c'est divertissant donc il faut
que les gens et les clés pour changer
leur comportement c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire avec ce livre et juste pour
finir sur ce que vous dites sur le fait
qu'on est dans une époque de clivage
justement les animaux c'est le sujet où
on peut réunir les gens au-delà des
clivages politiques quand vous regardez
tous les sondages c'est un des seuls
sujets ou que vous soyez de gauche de
droite d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite
tout le monde est d'accord en majorité
pour arrêter l'élevage intensif réduire
la chasse arrêter la corrida dans tous
les sondages on voit que quel que soit
la couleur politique des Françaises des
Français les gens sont très
majoritairement pour que la condition
des animaux s'améliore donc c'est un
sujet où on peut se réunir au-delà de
nos appartenances il est à condition
d'être informé parce qu'on a parfois
l'impression de d'agir pour pour la
planète sans comprendre que qu'un
écosystème c'est un tout faut des
solutions locales pour agir de manière
globale mais en fait comment la
biodiversité je prends souvent cette
image parce que je la trouve très
parlante c'est comme une maison
admettons que ce studio se soit notre
maison dans laquelle nous les êtres
humains on habite chaque brique de ce
studio est une espèce donc si vous en
enlevez quelques-unes il se passe rien
le studio tient toujours on se rend
compte de rien vous en enlevez quelques
dizaines bon il y a peut-être l'écran
derrière qui va bouger un peu mais ça va
continuer vous en enlevez une centaine
il y a un spot qui va tomber au milieu
de la table on va commencer à paniquer
et puis le jour où on enlève 1000
briques du studio tout le studio
s'effondre et nous les êtres humains on
est dans le studio et on meurt avec la
biodiversité c'est ça on a besoin de
diversité on a besoin de plein d'espèces
pour pouvoir nous les êtres humains
vivre on peut pas vivre seul dans dans
globale mais nous on fait quoi vous vous
avez mis deux pistes à faire déjà il y a
nos comportements individuels on peut
limiter les activités ou nos achats qui
détruisent la biodiversité la viande ça
en fait partie aller participer à des
spectacles qui exploitent les animaux
sauvages ça en fait partie et après on
pourrait parler de la question
écologique sur les déplacements etc mais
c'est une autre question mais surtout on
peut se réunir et passer à l'échelle
collective parce que les actions
individuelles ne suffisent pas si on est
chacun dans notre coin a changé quelque
chose mais qu'on ne le fait pas savoir
qu'on ne le dit pas aux politiques rien
ne va changer donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire une une solution très simple
interpeller les élus et surtout adhérer
aux associations de protection de la
nature et des animaux plus ces
associations seront
auront des moyens pour agir plus il y
aura de membres dans ces associations
plus les responsables politiques
écouteront ces associations si vous avez
d'un côté un million de chasseurs et de
l'autre des associations de protection
des animaux il y a quelques dizaines de
milliers de membres le politique
penchera en général toujours vers le
million de chasseurs le jour où il y
aura des millions de Françaises français
dans les associations de défense des
animaux les choses changeront très très
vite les choses senseront très très vite
c'est dur à dire merci beaucoup Merci à
VOUS clément pour les lapins ne mangent
pas de carottes donc ce livre édité il y
a pas longtemps à peine un mois et demi
aux éditions Fayard merci d'avoir été
notre merci pour ce matin